Ian Lake: I remember when dinosaurs ruled the earth
Android notifications were like this.
Oh my God.
Luckily, I saw less dinosaurs around me.
Android notifications have improved a lot
Permanent change of interface does not lead to
Experience an easy twist
Therefore, there is NotificationCompat.
It gives you a single interface across all levels of the software application
So you can focus on building
Best possible notifications.
I'm Ian Lick
And I'll show you how you can build great notifications
With the help of NotificationCompat
Enabling users to re-employ, whether on their phones or their hours
Or inside their car.
But I anticipate things a lot.
Let's start from the beginning.
Each notification has required parts - a small icon
Title and text.
To make a notification, use the NotificationCompat builder
Then create and send notifications.
Done
There is a serious mistake.
Clicking on this notice does nothing.
nothing!
We need a contentintent message that indicates
To the activity to be launched
When the user presses the notice.
But we can do more for notifications.
Specify the color to make the notice
Known as your app
Put a large icon, let us know now
Notifications from those who come.
You've already received a notification
Would like to press it
This title and text is initial.
All available on old operating rules.
But you should not stop on the initial.
Let us do this well
I mean very well
On Android 4.1 and the most advanced devices
Notifications can be expanded, which gives you
More space to work, bypass address
One line of text.
NotificationCompat gives you four designs
You can use it to improve your notifications
Especially when expanded
You will find BigTextStyle to see multiple lines of text,
Like long messages, this is perfect to see
Full message.
InboxStyle, to see a list of single line fonts
And BigPictureStyle to display -
I've guessed it - big picture when zoomed in.
And MediaStyle to add media control buttons directly
To your notifications.
So, it became our room to breathe
And give users a lot of information.
To pull them back to your program.
good.
But we are busy people.
Add works to your notifications
Give users quick access to the most important activities
Without spoiling their airspace
It does not mean that I will silence the voice of Joanna's notice.
But notifications are no longer on your mobile phone.
It is also on your wrist with your Android Wear device.
Any work you've added to your notification
Automatically reflected on Android Wear devices.
Allowing users to take over their tasks without carrying
Their phones up or open the program.
But your phone's experience is reflected in Android Wear
It has its limits
To make things great, you can use a program
WearableExtender of NotificationCompat.
Here all the magic features of Wear happen.
We talked about the reversal of activities.
With the WearableExtender program, you can build
A perfect set of activities to keep up with the clock
Includes voice response
These are rich activities that increase interaction, even though
The user has not opened your program.
Another example is adding a high resolution background image
It is the easiest way to get a fresh experience.
There is a lot you can for NotificationCompat
WearableExtender granted to you
Especially adding additional pages of data
Notifications for additional content and capability
To collect notifications in a single package
What shows you all the details on the hour,
And a telephone brief.
Well, there are a lot of things you can do on your wrist.
What about a car connected to Android Auto?
Here, messaging programs can use NotificationCompat
CarExtender to send a message or group of messages
In a conversation with Android Auto, where it is
It can be read aloud and the user responds to it
While focusing on leadership
If, using NotificationCompat,
You get a single application interface for all versions of Android
And support for further improvements by adding
Designs, activities and tools
To make great notifications for Android Wear and Android Auto.
There are many opportunities to make great notifications
Everywhere.
Start with NotificationCompat
By adding a support library to your project.
You'll need App Compat for media notifications
Or support for the v4 version
For all that NotificationCompat provides.
With all the tools you need to build great notifications
On your phone, tablet, clock or car you can only build
Better applications
[Music]